if you don't fight off go after with
such tenacity your goals and life what
are you what are you leaving a
significant other to admire about you
if you hang out with the light with a
dark clouds but the rain gonna get you
eventually so you go over there from
when to the dark cloud and about like
the Sun I didn't hear the naysayers when
they were like you too old to go to
California you don't hit by 25 you're
not going to make it I will be 46 this
year I am just touching the surface
she began her Hollywood career in
several guest roles on TV shows before
making her big breakthrough in baby boy
she's won a Golden Globe Award and been
nominated for two Emmy Awards she also
released a New York Times best-selling
autobiography titled
around the way girl she's Suraj chickpea
Henson and here's my take on her top ten
rules of success rule number one is my
personal favorite and I'd love to know
which one you guys like the best also
guys as you're watching if you hear
something that really resonates with you
please leave it down the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired also when you write it
down it's much more likely to lock into
yourself as well enjoy
what's the biggest risk you've taken
that you feel afraid of the biggest risk
I've taken minutes paid I was I cookie I
mean I was very nervous when I received
this grant she wasn't the most likable
character not playing some pretty edgy
characters but this one was particularly
a challenge because it was primetime
Network television and I wasn't sure how
people would receive her I mean she beat
her son with the room even though he
deserved it
um she calls once on a [ __ ] I mean it
was able to scary but I'm the type of
artist that if the role doesn't scare me
I don't want it because it's not going
to change me as a person so I took a
risk and that's what you do as artists
you just in feet-first
and you see where it goes and I knew
that we had something special
I don't just just eat first for any
project I knew this was something
special I knew that what Fox was trying
to do with Lee Daniels and any strong
we're trying to and what I was trying to
do was shake up television to faith you
know life is not safe and I think we did
that with the show so I was so proud to
be a part of this project and I'm so
proud that Fox believed in us and took a
chance because that's what art is about
isn't it taking chances taking risk I'm
graduated college and I have you know
just agree and fine arts and my dad saw
me coming and going to work every day
and he was like what are you doing and I
was like making a living what are you
talking about and I was in a
transitional period because my son and
father and I we had just broken up and I
had just agree and I was just living and
my dad saw it he was like how do you
expect to catch fish on dry land and I
wasn't he always spoke in metaphors
cousin can you just speak planning when
she was like how are you going to get
acting jobs when they're not here you
need to go to LA
where the jobs are so my family threw a
party we were broke they raised $700 and
I moved to LA and I took my son and my
dad may rest in peace he was like maybe
you should lead Marcell here no like I'm
not leaving my son my kids then I got
out and freaked out I said maybe I just
send them back and my dad was like no
that's your blessing
he's your blessing he's going to keep
you focused you were right your instinct
was right you should have taken them so
$700 my son is now 21 he's in school now
is in this user study didn't write and
look at me tell us about how while you
were in the movie of Benjamin Button
yeah and I don't want people to get
upset if not that I expected to be paid
as much as Brad Pitt or Cate Blanchett I
understand I'm just I'm new to the game
but what we were asking for didn't seem
like an astronomical amount you know
what I mean it was fair for me where I
was that time in my career and they
didn't come back with that it we were
heartbroken but see that's when you have
to check your ego because if I'd let you
go to eight I wouldn't have taken the
job and I would have missed my moment so
I had to set pride if I eat it suck it
up and I had to bite my tongue a lot and
I just had to stay focused on the bigger
picture but that's smart business yeah I
never get nervous anymore absolutely
immune
solutely you look like you just go up
there and you're not even you're not
even worried well there's a moment where
there's a fear that arises and I check
it it's not that I ignore it I go okay
that's fear and you know I'm a
faith-based person that's everything I
live right back yeah so faintness fear
can yeah they can't live together so
when it comes up you know I just check
it I go okay I recognize that but that's
not where I'm not going to live by rare
is not enough and that's what
nervousness is that's what that energy
is it's That moment to choose to give in
to that learn more to rise above you
know so we battle that everyday as
humans I am
you and I'm not a robot I love that you
realize that I had a choice
yeah because everybody kept asking me
what does it feel like what does it feel
like when you got the nomination that
little girl from Washington DC what did
it feel like when you heard your name
mine was a roller coaster ride I mean I
was nominated for this it wasn't good at
you know so I really put it out of my
head cuz I really do what I do for the
awards you know like you said if you're
passionate about your work all the
accolades will come you got to stay
focused on what God puts you on earth to
do so that's number five I finally get
to LA graduate I have a kid in college
and I have to pursue my dream because if
I don't what am i teaching my son so I
moved to California with 700 dollars in
my pocket and my toddler and I have to
fight the good fight because people are
telling me I can't you can't do this you
can are you crazy you're moving to hella
playing with your son you'll never make
it
I was 26 when I decided to come here
there's the age thing how are you too
old if you listen to people and if you
allow people to project their fears onto
you you won't live what if I believe
those people who saw me that I when I
became pregnant in college that I
wouldn't finish I walked across that
stage with my son on my hip and I
collected my degree my diploma
I didn't hear the naysayers when they
were like you're too old to go to
California you don't hit by 25 you're
not going to make it I will be 46 this
year I am just touching the surface I am
just getting started
everything in life that's coming to you
is going to come through you it starts
inside of you you know whether it's love
from another from a male from whoever
that love has to start within you if you
don't know how to take care of yourself
or care for yourself first you know how
are you going to how are you going to
teach someone else to you know if you
don't fight off go after with such
tenacity your goals in life what are you
what are you leaving a significant other
to admire about you it all starts with
you you know you're the temple and you
have control you're in a bad situation
it's up to you to get out of it you
can't give another human you the
responsibility of your happiness you
know my father told me a long time ago
he said life is choice driven and we're
talking about a man led a very rocky
path and you know once he had his
epiphany in life when he gave his life
to Christ and you know he started seeing
life in a more optimistic lens and
that's when he hit me with the taraji
you know life is choice driven I made
some bad choices in life but that
doesn't mean I can't change I can't
change those my mind to make better
choices for Monday so that's honest I've
lived by you got to have fun you got to
laugh to keep from crying there's a lot
going on in this world and I really like
to laugh outside I think you know they
were like you look so young I laugh a
lot I laugh at myself I don't take
myself too seriously and like I said I
surround myself with good energy because
energy is transferable if you hang out
with somebody with a dark cloud and the
rain gonna get you eventually so you go
over there and went to the dark cloud
and um I felt like the Sun I usually
don't turn I don't run from things that
scare me that usually means I should do
it if I feel too confident like I can do
this with my eyes closed then I'm not
servicing my fans to script the project
or the character why do it anybody else
out there more hungry might bless it
better you know so I
I love challenges what I love about art
is you have to take risks and that's the
work that sticks out the stuff is not so
safe
I sang about pips and [ __ ] at the
Oscars I did I sing it's hard out here
for a pimp
yeah they won my manager called and he's
like I had the script you know and I was
like what is and he's like it's a pilot
I was like but TV
did not tell you I've done with kitschy
so he's like read it I read it I'm like
this is stupid
I'm hip-hop love the dahm dahm do dahm
done oh oh my god oh my god oh my god
and then that fear thing comes up and
it's like okay well clearly this is a
challenge oh my god cookie we're going
to piss so many people off and then once
I wrapped my mind around how to deal
with cookie tell the truth you know tell
the wife she's this woman why she hit
her son with the broom if you stick to
the cheese people will love her they set
up a Skype session with Lee well yeah I
knew Lee but I didn't well I never
worked with Lee because you know the
last time we met was um in the audition
for precious and he wanted me for the
teacher and I was live what I want to
play precious that's the role I mean he
thought I was crazy but I was like a
monkey turn Charlize Theron into a
monster but yeah so that was the last
time I saw him on a job you know
potential job so he probably still was
thinking I'm gonna lose uber you won't
even know was gone but so he's in Japan
and we have a Skype session and you know
I'm not tripping I don't care I don't
have to go back to TV
I'm waiting for my big movie yeah
Spielberg is going to call me for sure I
know I say to him I really like the
script I think it's amazing I think this
game change and I think you know if I
can't do it with parents I'm not
interested I didn't even have the job it
did the scarf is he like that [ __ ] does
cooking me cookie is the American dream
she started from nothing and now she's
at the top started from the bottom now
we're here I mean that's like I'm the
American dream I wasn't born with a
silver spoon in my mouth you know
had a passion I had a dream and I've
died I dived in and I went for my dream
and Here I am
thank you guys so much for watching I
may dispute it because Aliyah Turner
asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it down the comments below
and I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of the clips
you heard today has the biggest impact
on you what lesson are you going to take
from this and immediately apply to your
life for your business leave it in the
comments below and I'm going to join in
the discussion finally I want to give a
quick shout out to Celia Lopez Celia
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word and for taking
that picture and tweeting it out as well
I really really really appreciate it and
I hope you're enjoying the book so thank
you guys so much for watching I believe
in you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
really what the activists said there was
no work order look cuz I look at my
resume I really can't complain I've been
an amazing amazingly I'm just an extreme
optimist that's how I was raised I mean
I came from a hood you can't be a
pessimist of the hood if you think it'll
make it out you know so I just never
thought about how bad it was I was
thinking about how can I make a
difference how can I make a change and
that's what I focused on I never thought
about wool with media so hard no one
gives me a job you're going to give me a
job let me in the room and eventually
you'll pay attention and I think that's
what people are witnessing now I've been
doing this for a long time and I stayed
in my lane I never hated on anyone I
think there's room for all of us and I
think that's what people are witnessing
someone who waited waited waited their
turn